calma en las calles de addis abeba
la guerra civil en etiopía no ha llegado
a la capital pero los extranjeros como
el francés alexander que slayer están
haciendo las maletas
los 900 franceses que viven en la
capital fueron notificados por su
embajada tienen que irse ahora la
mayoría de las sedes diplomáticas
occidentales también han instado a sus
ciudadanos a regresar a sus países de
origen
funden todos nuestros amigos se han ido
solo hay un puñado que se han quedado
porque tiene que hacerlo por su trabajo
o por elección fue en las últimas
semanas las fuerzas rebeldes del tigre
han avanzado por el país capturando las
ciudades de con bolsa y se guardó vida a
sólo 200 kilómetros de la capital el
primer ministro había met calar donado
con el premio nobel de la paz en 2019 se
dirigió el martes al frente de combate
mientras llamaba a los etíopes a
defender el país
incluso antes de instar a la defensa
estas mujeres de la capital ya estaban
trabajando duro por el esfuerzo que
supone la guerra
estamos haciendo todo lo que podemos por
los soldados del gobierno estamos
preparando cebada además estamos donando
sangre para los militares también
donamos dinero para la causa el frente
de liberación popular del tigre lleva
más de un año de enfrentamientos con el
gobierno el que fuera un partido
gobernante se retiró al tigre cuando fue
expulsado del poder y ahora se unió al
ejército de liberación oromo otro grupo
rebelde en su avance hacia la capital a
principios de este mes un informe de las
naciones unidas- se reveló que los
civiles han sufrido la mayor parte de la
violencia de ambos bandos incluyendo
ataques indiscriminados
violaciones y desplazamientos forzados
así como miles de muertos el número
exacto es difícil de saber en medio de
un cierre continuo de internet y de los
servicios de comunicación en la región